hey historians kim from khan academy
here with a quick guide to the 2020 ap
us history exam
i'm gonna go over the details about the
new exam format and how the scoring
system has changed okay here's what you
need to know first the exam is taking
place on friday may 15 2020. the time
depends on where you live so you'll get
all the information you need on when and
how to sign in from the college board if
you've registered for the exam
the overall scoring system for the exam
hasn't changed you'll still receive a
score between 1 and 5
and it's still up to colleges to decide
how many credits they'll award you based
on that score
the college board says they're confident
that most colleges will accept this
year's ap scores
just as they would for any other year
you'll have 45 minutes to take the exam
plus 5 minutes for uploading at the end
of that period you can type the exam if
you've got access to a computer or you
can write it out longhand on paper and
take pictures of your essay if you want
to upload it through your smartphone
if you need help accessing technology so
you can take and submit the exam reach
out to the college board as soon as you
can i'll put a link to the forum in the
description
so now let's talk about the format of
the exam
it's a little different the whole exam
is just going to be one document based
question dbq so there won't be any
multiple choice or short answer
questions or a long essay the good news
is that this year there will be fewer
documents than your standard dbq five
documents instead of seven
and one of those will be something other
than a text-based source so a political
cartoon a photograph
map something like that and the exam
will also cover fewer periods of us
history
just periods three through seven so that
goes from 1754
or the start of the seven years war
through 1945 the end of world war ii
the exam is going to be open book so you
can have any books or notes you want
with you but you can't copy and paste
from sources or collaborate with other
students so don't text your friends the
minute you get the prompt the college
board has said they're going to crack
down very hard on cheating and they'll
use plagiarism software to detect
similar essays
all right now let's talk about how this
tbq will be scored it's a little
different from previous dbqs since there
are fewer documents and less time
overall you'll be able to earn up to 10
points instead of seven
so let's go through the points you can
earn one by one
first there are the thesis and
contextualization points these are the
same as they have been in past exams you
get one point for including a
historically defensible claim that gives
a line of reasoning in either the
introduction or the conclusion this
means you've got to answer the question
prompt with an argument that's factual
and you need to say why you think it's
true contextualization gives a broader
sense of what was happening in the time
period in a way that's relevant to your
thesis
so if the question is about
industrialization in the gilded age
you want to explain the context of the
expansion of factory work and
urbanization
not something about the impact of the
dawes act on indigenous people in the
west just because something's happening
at the same time doesn't mean that it's
relevant context for the argument you're
making okay now let's talk about the
evidence points this is the area where
there are the most differences from the
usual dbq scoring here's how you can
earn the points
you get one point for describing the
content of two of the five documents
accurately that means not just quoting
from them but showing your understanding
of what's happening in the document
and you can earn another point for using
those two documents to support your
argument tying them back directly to
your thesis
and you can earn another point by going
above and beyond by accurately
describing four documents and using
those to support your argument too then
there's evidence beyond the documents
you can earn up to two more points by
bringing in one or two more pieces of
evidence to support your thesis drawing
on your own knowledge of the material
now it's not just mentioning some other
piece of evidence you have to show that
you know what you're talking about when
you use it so you can't just say another
example of reform was the temperance
movement you need to say something like
the temperance movement was another
reform movement that encouraged
americans to make a voluntary change for
the better by abstaining from alcohol
the analysis and reasoning points are
also slightly different this year so
instead of requiring you to provide a
source analysis for three of the seven
documents
the college board is being considerably
more lenient and awarding one point for
explaining the relevance of the point of
view purpose situation or audience
of one of the provided documents
and another point for doing so for a
second document
remember that your source analysis needs
to go deeper than just a surface mention
don't just say the emancipation
proclamation was written in the context
of the civil war but something like
lincoln issued the emancipation
proclamation after the us army won the
battle of antietam hoping that the
victory and the new commitment to ending
slavery would prevent european powers
from allying with the confederacy so
make sure that you explain why the extra
information you provide about the source
connects back up to your thesis the last
point is for demonstrating a complex
understanding of the topic this is the
same as in the old rubric so you get a
point for corroborating qualifying or
modifying your argument in other words
you
show that you understand that history
isn't neat and tidy there are exceptions
ways that historical actors or movements
fell short of their goals or ideals or
other sides to consider when making a
statement about the past
now i know all of this is a lot to take
in i'm going to provide a link to the
new rubric in the description so you can
check it out for yourself but in essence
it's just a shorter form of the dbq so
don't sweat the details you've got this